see now that's a fish oh that's cool
he's cute or she you can't even tell and
but but what is that fish thinking is it
like is it nostalgia is it rage
maybe I'm just projecting but you can't
really tell what it's thinking it's a
mistress and enigma but watch this
eyebrows now you see now this fish has
an emotional life you can you can really
empathize with do you want a fish to
have eyebrows that's the scene asking
yes so is that so hard is that so wrong
and you do that please of your next big
genetic project
well sylvia earle loves every fish in
the sea no matter what with or without
eyebrows and I asked her about her love
of the ocean just tell me speak the love
and let's see what you say well I think
of people who love the ocean many of
them just like sailing the ocean or
surfing surfing right so swim the ocean
to them is a surface and to you it's a
three-dimensional the ocean is the rest
part universe people the ocean is a
surface right no it's a juicy part in
the middle it's this part that's and
it's alive that's the thing that if
people think of the ocean they think
rocks and water and you know a place to
sail or swim or to dump things or to
take things out of the ocean but no the
ocean is a it's a living system so
Laurie first remind us what it means for
the ocean to be a living system because
to most people it's just water and it
contains living things but to think of
it as a living system take us there you
so in the same way that a forest with
birds and trees and bugs that are all
interacting is a living system the
oceans the same way it's not only full
of life but it's all interacting
together in a in a connected way that
kind of keeps it all function isn't it
just big fish eat little fish
part of it but there's a whole complex
food web there that most people just
don't see and take into consideration
[Music]